um
so uh welcome to the uh beyond worst
case complexity panel
so we're gonna
be talking about um you know criticizing
our favorite way of analyzing algorithms
and i have a very we have a very very
distinguished panel with us uh
there's piotr berman
avram blum
uh
we have a very tired moderator tonight
[Laughter]
got the rest of the names right
um
no
but that one's difficult so i get a pass
on it
and um so what what i'm going to do is
uh
have the panelists give a short
presentation of their views on the
subject then i'm going to ask them some
leading questions try to
get some discussion going
and then
we'll also take questions at any time
from the audience
okay
um
so we'll start with uh
ravi
so i have your presentation
oh do you want to you could also just
oh you would do the piece
oops that did not work so well
no that did not
[Music]
how about this one here
oh okay that's it yeah
okay and you're here now so so i i'm
going to start with the famous quote
which goes nothing focuses the mind like
and usually the likes are debts and
taxes but there are other versions of it
i would like to add to that
worst case complexity
um exactly because the complexity it's
not the work of cricket it's wcc i
abbreviate workspace complexity
since the 70s worst case complexity has
focused the thesis mind rather well and
sharply
resulting in some great intellectual
advancement so i want to finish wcc on
this slide
well they're just closer to you okay is
that better yeah yeah so
oh we start again
no it's not going
it's just keeping so it's resulted in
some great intellectual advances
um
in both algorithmic ideas and hardness
proofs both sides np hardness for
instance here's an example
um one more
common refrain one common refrain that
you hear it's not practical the time
bounds or too high
well
the theory aesthetic always is the clean
abstract model which doesn't bring out
all the complications of reality but
serves as a foundation for scientific
advances
in that wcc has been a great success for
the last 50 years
now there are other complaints
one i won't deal with
one complaint is this complaint is wcp
outpace simplicity and
generality of the algorithm i won't deal
with that instead i'll deal with
something that's unusual perhaps
ignore it for now this is a very
eventful call
okay actually now i'm getting nervous
come why don't you come back over behind
the podium
yeah
so worst case data can give us
pessimistic time estimates this is
obvious and heard a lot
and uh
one attempt to tackle that the first
attempt is average case analysis
but a less well-known or less heard
about complaint is in fact worse
it can give you wrong conclusions so for
example if you don't have
if you have insufficient data for
scientific or social phenomena you run
an algorithm what you get out of it is
not going to make sense right
now what's the general complaint here's
a general complaint i want to focus on
wcc has in fact focused our mind on
something but it has focused it away
from understanding data
this is overstated i pardoned by this is
all i can put into one bullet highly
qualified but i would i'm saying we're
ignoring data
highly qualified again
so statistics and machine learning do
worry about what data looks like they
build models of data
in the main the models have a feature
that data points are independent of each
other there's no adversary coordinating
the whole data set
okay and they're picked from some
general distribution not necessarily
uniform
so is there a happy marriage for the
future you take these data models
and prove
that there are certain properties that
hold under them and then in the worst
case data with those properties we prove
time bounce
the answer is i think yes but instead of
describing generalities i'm going to
give you one snippet and this is my last
slide so here's a possible talk in the
next 10th 20th anniversary of simon's
and the main theorem of the talk is that
this particular what particular
self-driving program
is
uh
559 safe index of 5 9 safety so that's
that
okay now it's just not one single
theorem i want to point to a lot of
theory that underpins that theory would
have in the process accomplish the
following before going to this theorem
first would have formulated a stochastic
model of data
second would approved possibly
deterministic properties that hold with
high probability under the model
given enough data this is data
sufficiency which plays a big role
nowadays
and
will the third part would have proved
that for any even worst case data with
satisfying the properties the program
works
so i just want to summarize in two lines
what the general picture is um well
before that won't you feel safer reading
this proof before you drive the
self-driving car yeah i guess let's be
as satisfied
yeah
now
properties
are possibly deterministic as i said
they're really explanation of features
in deep network or whatever you're using
which at the moment is solely lacking we
don't have explanations of what dnns do
and theory could actually answer that
question the second is data sufficiency
which we know under the name sample
complexity and we have our own beautiful
theory for supervised learning a lot of
pac learning we don't have a theory for
unsupervised learning and that is one of
the agenda items that underlies such a
theorem
okay now that's all i have to say thank
you thank you
[Applause]
no you keep that one
okay
your powerpoint skills are amazing
yes but amazing in what direction
um
it's already here
is this yours yeah this display thing
close this
okay okay great thank you
uh my my view is uh i should say much
less exciting uh no self-driving cars no
whales no mermaids but uh um
it's
three slides uh three problems uh that i
think are still going to drive a lot of
work in the next decade the first is
planted clique um actually we can first
talk about clique in a random graph
so uh we worst case is we sort of
understand the answer but uh how about
in random graph we know there's a two
plus two two log n
greedy's log n we don't know how to find
one point one and the first director of
the simon says should ask this question
uh is still open um the current best we
know how to do is log in plus root login
tell me if you know how to do login plus
root login
ah okay let me tell you it's very easy
so um so you have a little nugget so
login is just you take a vertex check
out what it's connected to it works
connected to both of them that's it
that's bill's login okay
to get login plus root like you do the
following
you
build do this greedy thing but you stop
at one minus epsilon log n
okay
now when you have one minus epsilon log
n
n to the epsilon of the remaining
vertices will still be connected to all
of these guys not between each other but
they'll be still connected to all of you
because it's probably half
okay so you have n to the epsilon
connected to one minus epsilon log n
and now in n to the epsilon you know
there's a two epsilon log n
uh click because that's still a random
graph you haven't looked at how do you
find that brute force search
because that's n to the two epsilon
squared log n time set epsilon to one
over root log n you've got root r
can you do better than this i don't know
but it would be great uh okay planted
clique so this is if you make k much
bigger than log n so jeremy introduced
this to try to make progress root n is
where we are stuck uh for all kinds of
uh algorithm classes low degree sq
the right versions of sos for this at
least to refute the existence of this
click
but it won't surprise me if tomorrow one
of you or uh phi gay comes up with a
root and over login
nothing nothing stopping it really
okay
um
random planted ksat kcsb sorry very much
in the same vein but
this one is very rich right because uh
we have these phase transitions you know
that statistical physics physicists have
observed and now serial computer
scientists are formalizing um and and is
terrific we understand certain things
about where these thresholds come up but
they also exhibit these computational
gaps statistical computational gaps so
in particular we know that with n log n
clauses clauses
you know it becomes unsatisfiable
with high probability but
to to to to prove this or to refute it
you need n to the r over two plus where
r is basically uh um
the the the how many way independent
your your clause distribution is if it's
r minus one independent but not
independent that's r okay so in
particular there's a hypothesis but if i
give it says that just three sat maybe
needs n to the 1.5 clauses even though
you know that after n it's already
unsatisfied
fantastic problem right and very
different from the usual and this is my
last slide random games
so um so if you if your payoff matrices
are uh
are independent entries from
at least we know for gaussian and
uniform it probably holds for much more
general distributions then you can find
a national a real natural equilibrium
in polynomial time
so that's just how about smooth that
would have been great right how about if
instead of random games i take an
arbitrary payoff matrix i i perturb it
in the usual smooth sense and then now
can you get something
there turns out that
it would have been nice but it actually
implies an epsilon nash equilibrium and
and apparently now this is a hard
problem unless you think that t-pad can
be solved faster than
uh faster than exponential time
so so even approximate smooth is hard so
what's what's a good model in between or
what can we do for games beyond random
games
so
yeah so so so uh since russell gave us a
very general instruction and
i and the album at the two camp without
doing slides and so give the
you can see the case are different and
so so so instead of giving a concrete
conjecture as uh the early two i i would
like to just offer a little bit of
perspective where somehow did my own
thinking over the years towards the
notion of beyond worst case analysis
and
because we are living a changing time
for computer science right everything is
rising there's a lot of
new domains that we enter and usually
those times somehow give us a new
language and new measurements
and for myself basically
you know
associations who clearly
take all my classes in
worst case analysis and polynomial time
computation and then i suddenly
transferred from usc to cmu as a student
and at that time cmu however strong they
are has only a few theory students
and most of my classmates were not from
theory
and and because us cmu randomized the
the the the students i suddenly
have been exposed to things that was not
teaching theory class right so the first
thing somehow impacted me i think could
be example just impact every generation
with their own instance is
in cmu about this development is it's
called bdd in a binary decision diagram
which is a critical tool for a circuit
design
and
my office mate was studied under randy
brine so every day he's telling me bdd
and very quickly i realized the whole
thing is np complete i just shut down
and but he's continued to look for this
particular ordering of the pulling odor
and then to make this diagram in finite
state automata versus short
and then they have consequences if that
is small then some other thing had great
thing happened
and uh so as a psychiatrist for a while
i was very fascinated by the fact that
they find this natural way to attack
obviously an empty heart problem
right and so clearly bdd has been a
theory has been developing and in fact
uh i was surprised years later to read
this beautiful
blog from lipton he wrote a long
essays about the bdd
and so so i said the wonder that also
deeply impacted myself as a student at
cmu
and
so so then after i graduated i went to
nasa so do
in that case uh
web is a super computing you know
everyone tried to predict earthquake
fluid dynamic model and so on
and i went to nasa and this this man his
name is of course simon i think he's in
burke near berkeley lawrence berkeley
lab
and and
so he was a student from uh berkeley
uh from numerical analysis and then he's
specialized in
writing language code and solving eigen
values
so so so then suddenly nineties happen
everyone is running parallel machines
and people want to do graph prediction
and when we were looking around
everything isn't being complete
and so i went to nasa and the first
thing for simon said to me he said
xiaomi you have to read our experiments
it's so sharply find a great prediction
everywhere
and there must be a theory in this
and at that time i was thinking i said
you know how can you convert just this
observation to a theory and at the
beginning i haven't already analyzed but
somehow it deeply registered to me that
this very popular code which i find in
nasa each thinking machine corporation
in intel everywhere they run in this
code and just beautiful right if you
look at the cut it look
beautiful for the finite element with
this two dimensional three dimension
and when i left
nasa to go back to mit
for simon again said to me he's a u.s
study geometry and graph theory i really
hope you can prove a theorem on
spectrograph theory on this white
spectrum for teaching work
so so so this actually eventually lead
to uh me for a lot you know dan spielman
is a really world expert inspector graph
theory back then study you know the
expanders for communication for many
things so so so
so so for simon's thing really injected
in my mind also
there's something really practical
people really love but clearly in the
worst case
it didn't happen right
it's an mp hard problem
and then as long as that then began to
as i began to go to those conferences
outside the theory and i began to be
exposed to like conjugate gradient
which is this beautiful
algorithm using for solving linear
systems
and it's primary choice not by worst
case but by condition number
right if your condition nice number is
small quantity with conjugate gradient
is fast
right so then
when you expose again to linear in the
linear programming then render grocery
not also stated in almost parallel way
about this condition not very small so
so so it really gave you a sense that
you know you have this landscape
of complexity
and then somehow in different fields
with this practice or in theory they're
able to somehow find some kind of
classifier to say that is
a condition under which things are
efficient
right so then when we go back to our own
theory
i began to deeply appreciate an earlier
result
by uh lipton and tarjan
so basically he said that
if you have planar graph then you can
have small separator and that linear
system can be solved fast right so so
it's also have this kind of a condition
across the landscape and be able to
identify
a domain and
then when you go to intel these are
disagreed results because our circuit
all look like planar
right so somehow match their condition
right so so i feel this type of
condition clearly may not just derive
from a
theoretical study we try to find the
good classifier but somehow in practice
it might just be there
and these require a theoretical
uh uh you know uh
investigation to see how how we can
classify them right so so in something a
large uh domain that if you think about
algorithm analysis
it's really like a dimensional reduction
right because we have this very high
dimensional data called the landscape of
computing right whenever i give an
algorithm you have this exponential
dimensional space data
right for each instance you have certain
complexity for a particular algorithm
and we more algorithm around this
landscape also changing
and in some sense we try to measure them
it's really become a
dimensional reduction right because
how do we summarize it's a
exponential dimensional space
into a is a single function low
dimensional function also or in which
way we can find a
meaningful sub domain that somehow
interpret this efficiency or other
quantities so
so from this perspective i feel like
each generation probably will be exposed
more and more
to the things that we just never
realized before to be an important
condition
and this could be one of the reasons to
continue to drive our desire for going
beyond worst case right because
worst case is just one way to do
dimensional reduction of your
exponential dimensional
landscape and there's many other
possible meaningful way and maybe
eventually there will be axiom about
what is a good
measure and
so so
and maybe we can begin to put in certain
desirable properties that may cover
certain applications of domain so that's
uh my opening for now
hi
so uh let's see um
so i think what i'm going to talk uh
just a little about is so how did i
personally get interested in in
non-worst case analysis and and then
maybe sort of uh then kind of now what
do i think is sort of uh some of the
most exciting uh things uh so in terms
of how i personally got interested um
when i was in graduate school i i was
interested in approximation algorithms i
was particularly looking at graph
coloring and there's a problem where
there's this huge gap so you know you
have a three colorable graph and the
best we could do is get end to some
power a number of colors okay and that's
kind of what i was working on
and um uh you know and it's just a
frustrating problem uh and uh you know
you start looking around you know i saw
that they were
you know plenty of results for for rent
for the average case you know so for
random three colorable graphs that
showed that you know very simple
strategies could find you an exact
optimal solution you know on average for
random three colorable graphs um but
then when you look at them you know one
thing i was noticing is that some of
them were much more brittle than others
so what do i mean by brittle
it says this funny thing that you know
a random three-colorable graph looks
like a particular so a random graph
looks like a particular graph right so
you kind of it sounds funny because it's
like most right or average but really
you know it's kind of like what does
what do most
pixel you know black and white pixel
images look like if you you know if you
take a you know a pixel image and you
flip each each uh
pixel black or white independently what
you're going to get is snow right like
on the old tv set so
that you know they're they're all very
particular and some algorithms were very
you know exactly tied to it whereas
others seemed you know
more reasonable and so you know what do
you mean more reasonable like how do you
quantify that and then it kind of struck
me that well if you imagine an adversary
creating the graph but their decisions
about what edges to put in or not put in
we're going through a noisy channel
then
actually some of these algorithms would
still work as long as there was at least
some non-negligible amount of noise in
this channel and whereas others you know
really relied on the thing being you
know exactly a random graph and so you
know this
uh
this kind of struck me as something that
you could use as a way to go between a
random case and the adversarial case we
think of an adversary constructing
something through a noisy channel and
that just like approximation ratio you
could use this as another kind of
yardstick so you know approximation
ratio is one yardstick well how much
randomness how much noise do you need to
add to the adversary's decisions would
mean another very reasonable yardstick
and then you could try to you know
optimize that so i guess that was kind
of uh
you know and uh
and then at some point i was talking to
my dad because this is how you know
conversations go in our family and and
he said uh
oh oh that's that you know in
cryptography that would be called a
semi-random source of randomness and so
so
uh okay so this became a semi-random
model um so anyway uh
so um
so i guess my initial interest is that
you know
trying to get other yardsticks right um
as ways to try to make progress on some
problems or maybe you're you're banging
your head against the wall working on a
more traditional yardstick uh i guess i
would say that right now there's just
two things i find particularly exciting
one is that you know
the the uh
the power of deep networks for example
has has really shown that you have these
these
these uh
algorithms that are working
on things that people want to do
where uh you know worst case they are
they should be you know they're all
the the the sort of the way you would
code up uh you know what do we mean by
training the training problem those are
all np hard they should require you know
exponential amount of time to solve and
they should require huge amount of
samples to do it but nonetheless by
using very natural gradient descent
based algorithms people are able to do
instances they want to solve very well
efficiently and from not very much
samples and so if as theoreticians we
want to provide insight we need to
somehow go you know beyond a traditional
worst case view you know whatever that
means
uh so that's one thing the the other
thing i find exciting is is kind of
several lines of recent work on using
machine learning kind of in algorithm
design that
uh and kind of uh
uh in fact even thinking of algorithm
design as a machine learning problem and
i'm thinking here of kind of work uh
some of these directions spearheaded by
nina balkan at cmu and some by pyotr uh
here on this panel uh on kind of
connecting machine learning and
algorithm design which i think also has
you know potential to give us a new way
to think about what are our goals in
designing algorithms what does it mean
to come up with a you know good solution
maybe you know instead of competing with
ops we want to compete with the best
algorithm in some family or something
like that in a way that these methods
can really help us with so those are the
things i'm personally you know very
excited by right now
thank you
hopefully it's working for you
does this work
uh nope
hello can you hear me all right good
all right so uh russell asked us all to
share
personal experiences with beyond worst
case analysis
so let me start by saying that uh
i'm personally a big fan actually a huge
fan of how worst case analysis
i have
always been i'm not sure if we're
supposed to say it you know we're
supposed to criticize
but
you know it's a it's a really
fundamental uh framework and therefore
for a long list of reasons
uh ravi articulated some of the more uh
intellectual reasons you know it
stimulates certain you know way of
thinking and so on but uh i i think that
uh you know there are some uh i would
say very practical reasons right why uh
wealth case standards is uh important
and uh you know the chief reason is that
if you have a west case algorithm it
always works okay you just don't have to
worry about
you know if you have an efficient worst
case algorithm right you can you you can
always use it right
and uh this is uh you know something
that uh you know like as a theoreticians
we often take for granted but um you
know it uh it's worth repeating
especially when you know talking to
other fields you know like maybe
information to your your signal
processing where you know worst case is
not always the the main paradigm right
so you know for starters you know if you
have a worst case algorithm you don't
have to worry about adversaries right
adversarial effects on the running time
i mean they don't happen that often but
they do
sometimes right and if you have a
wastegation algorithm you just don't
have to worry about that
now a more
typical situation is that the input to
your problem might not still be
adversarial but that could be just very
messy right because uh
you know what often happens is that uh
the algorithm is not just a you know
like a one-shot a module but uh it's a
part of a bigger system
you know the system can change you know
the output of one component becomes
input to another
right so the you know in principle it
might be possible to characterize the
distribution of you know the input to
your algorithm but uh it's very hard
right and can change over time so if you
don't have to do it uh and you know and
that's exactly the the worst case i'll
guarantee that the algorithm provides
you know then you can just stop plug and
play and you know not worry
that you know if you change the system
you know like somehow your algorithm
could stop working okay
so so these are the big benefits of the
worst case analysis
but at the same time you know uh
it's important to be realistic right so
i think about the you know west case
algorith as a holy grail
right so you know of course this is
something that you can aspire to
right but uh you know it's it will not
always happen right so you know like uh
uh here is a you know list of things
that uh we could want from our
algorithms right you probably have your
own list
and uh you know it's uh
uh you want to aspire you know for your
anger to satisfy all of this but uh you
know i don't know about you uh but uh if
i only published papers you know i was
algorith all these constraints you know
my publication list would have been much
shorter right
so uh you know so it's important to be
realistic right i mean you have to pick
and choose and uh uh
you know like a kind of leaf with the
trade-offs
uh between uh these are different
aspects and you know like unfortunately
there are trade-offs between you know
worst case guarantees and some other
aspects right so you know if you have a
worst-case algorithm uh presumably it's
not gonna be as simple as it's possible
right because uh you know you have to
provision for corner cases right so this
is uh going to complicate uh your
algorithm right and uh for the same
reason uh you know if you have an
algorithm sufficient in worst case it
might end up not being as efficient in
practice as you would hope for right
besides because you have to over
provision
uh respect to cases which just not gonna
happen the tough okay
so you know so it's uh it's important
you know to understand the trade-offs
between these things and uh you know
this is something that fascinated me uh
for a long time
uh i haven't really done uh much about
it uh except for uh
in 2013 we had a working group
by national research council
uh which addressed many of these topics
and uh we discussed it a lot we agreed
that uh it's very important uh we had
absolutely no idea what to do about it
uh so instead of proposing solutions you
know we just decided to do the second
best thing which is uh leave it as an
open problem right
all right so uh so basically that was um
the status quo at least from my
perspective until
uh recently
now what's changed is that uh over the
last few years
uh there is uh maybe not a new but
certainly a rejuvenated line of research
uh that uh
uh you know go under goes under several
names you know i'm referring to it as a
machine learning for
algorithms but uh you know there are
many different uh
names for it
the names are not that important uh
you know what's important is the essence
and the essence of this line of research
is essentially to use uh machine
learning uh to improve the performance
of classical algorithms right and by
classical algorithms i really mean
classical problems right so things like
sorting you know searching and so on
right there are not things that
you would normally think about as being
in domain of machine learning
but uh
you know this a new line of uh research
you know makes it actually possible uh
to use ml to solve problems like that
there are various ways of doing it you
know you can use machine learning as
predictors or uh you can just optimize
over space of algorithms
uh
and uh you know like the reason that uh
at least to me it's a particularly
appealing
is that um
you know
what has been uh observed is that um in
many situations
uh you don't run the algorithm just as a
one-shot
but you keep solving the same problem
you know day by day or or week by week
right of course we are not solving the
same problem right it's not the same
input
uh because uh like if it was really the
same input you know you could just uh no
you don't have to solve it many times
right so you are switching you know from
input to input but they are those inputs
are similar but not quite different
right so if you can somehow uh
characterize or extract those uh
commonalities between different inputs
characterize distribution and exploit it
to make your regulars more efficient you
know then you would get a big win
okay
at the same time what happened over the
last uh
decade or so is that uh machine learning
i mean machine learning was you know
around for a while but uh especially
over the last 10 years it got really
good right so it got really good you
know extracting uh useful patterns from
the data so now if you comp you know
combine the set of things right you have
a good pattern extractor
uh then if you can somehow use those um
uh patterns to improve your algorithms
you know that potentially offers uh
lots of
benefits
and uh this is something that uh many
people including myself have been very
uh interested over the last few years
it's been a very active field you know
just uh over the last uh
to one year there has been three
workshops actually two of them happened
one is still upcoming at this
coming stock
and uh
you know there are already a bunch of
success stories uh and i should
emphasize those success stories are not
only in things that you would associate
normally with machine learning but uh
you know these are uh
classic combinatorial problems like data
structure online algorithm and whatnot
uh so this is a line of research that i
am personally very interested
in the one lesson
you know that
became apparent to me is that uh
respect to this particular line of
research
design is uh as important as analysis
right and this is because uh uh you know
many of the algorithms that i use
machine learning i mean they don't even
exist right so it's not the case that
there are algorithms that uh work well
we have to analyze them
in many cases we have to figure out
right how to use machine learning you
know to speed up i know searching or
something
right so uh design in this context is uh
at least as important as analysis but of
course analysis is also very important
because you
have to understand you know how does not
good work and when they are efficient
uh so
uh just to summarize uh i love worst
case uh i also love beyond worst case
uh i think that uh you know there are
some very interesting opportunities for
marrying the two and uh you know i'm
very excited
about this line of research
thanks thank you
[Music]
so um
i'm gonna ask some questions that kind
of like pick up on these themes
um
so i'm gonna skip the warm-up question
that i mentioned but so once we um
start going beyond worst case if we're
doing worst case analysis we don't
really have to think about what the
input looks like that's just given to us
but if we're going if we're trying to go
beyond worst case analysis it seems to
me we have to like think about the back
story of the input
where that how that input was generated
what it means
so um
when you think about going beyond worst
case complexity
what kind of backstory are you thinking
about
for for where that instance came from
and uh so robby maybe i'll start with
you
well i i was saying stochastic models
for instance of data is one place to
look to see what's going on
i mean uh because we don't we can't do
it perfectly of course
and worst case i i should say like peter
worst case is certainly an important
thing to have around for complete
guarantees
but i think stochastic or other models
of data would be nice to have for
problems for which there is a lot of
data
okay
yeah generative models of various types
like have been very useful like we
haven't compressed sensing or in
matrix recovery whether it's
random or stochastic block models and so
on
but your question is what do i have and
what should i think of the data is yeah
maybe some kind of generative model what
is generating it is an important
question and i guess for example these
these scans that
courses talked about are part of this
game yeah
so you so let me pick up on that so the
gans you have to like adapt there is a
distribution
is being but it's being also being
learned and adapted
in the different stages and so your
algorithm has to
sort of play against an active player
trying to figure out hard instances for
it right is that
yeah
but then that's going to like converge
to worst case isn't it is it you tell me
if you play this game does it mean that
the you because you still have to they
still have to stick to a distribution
yeah
in the limit
okay
so
um do you think this is the having like
a fixed stochastic model is a good
i i think in general probably uh clearly
the data comes from different reasons
and uh one is to have the like model to
generate the data we see the other one
sometimes is intrinsic properties
that the practical problems somehow
possess so for example
years ago when i was working at intel i
had a few industry
exposure and working with one of my
former uh office meet from cmu
and at that time we had tried to write
in transistor level
emulate simulators for the painting
and
uh he they want to do you know there's a
parallel simulation but there's a lot of
depending back then compared with the
the machine size
and uh so
my friend manfred carroll his name
has this intrinsic belief he said this
has to be efficiently simulated but on
paranormal machine because the intel
circuits use so much pipeline
that you know they're parallel circuits
they're they're they're designed for
efficiency and within the efficiency
there's just a lot of
native parallelism
then he said
if the circuit is
parallel there must be a way to enhance
this in your simulator to capture it
right so so so to a larger degree also
for example if you look at a lot of uh
either power law or scientific computing
when they are doing like uh
rocket simulation or uh airplane
dynamics
and most of the the the finest element
graph
they have certain conditions right
because geometrically they cannot have
taylor expansion go wrong so the taylor
expansion gave a certain numerical
condition and remarkably some of those
conditions are intrinsic also related to
efficiency or the quantity of solutions
right so so that may not be directly in
the generator model but somehow because
the nature of application has a certain
property
and if we are able to somehow harness
that property or machine learning that
property that maybe one can somehow
adapt to the yeah right so um so i think
this brings up an important point so
many of the instances that we're trying
to solve
were either created you know either are
created by nature
in some sense
or are created
by human effort
and
uh for for those two like backstories
the
properties you know the humans the
people the systems that people are
designing creating the instances
might also give us clues as to the
nature of the instances and the best uh
pro algorithmic approaches to solve them
is that what you're saying
right right so for example like alvin's
talk about the semi-random
were eventually inspired us to do the
smooth analysis to a larger degree so
when you go to
talk to
you know the practical people at that
time
because you know i think in early late
90s
unicef organized i think the car
together with property machine they
organized several nsf
uh uh conference talking about the
future of theory of computing how can we
be closer to practice
and so then when you go to practitioner
and they always say practical data is
somehow there's like a folklore there
but but when you ask people what is
practical data
it is very hard for people to define
naturally
and eventually you know when the end i
was talking to folks how do you model
certain practical data some of our
friends suddenly said one thing if you
look at stock market
you know if you say ibm stock is 170
you believe it
these are the
you see ibm's stock is a 120 you believe
it
or if you see ibm's stock is zero
dollars you don't believe it well ibm
stock is milling but so somehow he said
you know when you measure the stock this
uh it's not a number it's really a model
plus something noise right so so so i
think those are to a larger degree like
rm said that when you look at certain
graphs it's like a graph a form then
because certain indecision or certain
inability to
perfectly design somehow certain nature
comes so that's
another property right it's almost like
you can see it's a generative model too
yeah like combined worst case to
something right but on the other hand
these kind of generic property that
often
uh innovate that right yeah so um um
what's your viewpoint do you think that
sometimes the data is kind of like
the idea is generated in a way that
makes a certain algorithmic approach is
ideal
so let's see
uh let me give two answers
yes and now okay now now uh let's see so
so i mean one answer is you know which
maybe is along the lines of of this of
machine learning based algorithms would
be that something like regret so uh or
more fine-grained analysis like what you
would like is an algorithm that if your
data if the typical instances are nice
you do well is that typical and says
they're not nice and you don't do so
well and that you know you end up doing
as well as you could hope to do given
how nice the instance like so you could
one way to think of this is you know you
want to really
you know more fine-grained kind of
guarantee something you want like an
optimistic algorithm something like that
right so if the data is good you do well
uh the other thing i would say is that
for for problems where
yeah i mean you know
why are we able like why does gradient
descent seem to work for training deep
networks right so so there is something
about the instances and so forth that i
accept maybe i would say like this when
we define the problem we typically
define things syntactically in a clean
way you know sat is the
tsp problem
we define it but the in the instance is
sure they they belong to that clean
problem but this clean problem you know
it's clean in the syntactic way but it's
conf it's complicated in a hardness way
and maybe there are properties of the
actual instances that you know are
allowing these simple algorithms to work
but they are not captured by the way
we've defined it so what are they how do
we get a handle on that how do we give
some theoretical like guidance or
insight or something
you know i i i i don't know how but but
we need you know so from that point of
view it's more like uh going beyond this
sort of clean problem statement just to
something that maybe can give us insight
into why these algorithms are doing
something yeah so um so
uh
sometimes as i when i present like np
completeness to my grad students
i usually say you know np completeness
is about the way you formulated the
problem it's not about the instances
that have actually come up um
and you can always over generalize and
formulate a problem to be and be
complete
if you're
um so but
identifying parameters
okay so i'm gonna move on to santosh and
say maybe is there is sorry
why am i
my mentor
okay
i'm going to go home soon
uh
so you mentioned like the unreasonable
success in machine learning in
designing algorithms uh
is there
you know is it
a function of how
how we define
the problems
that we're asking these things to solve
are we being too rigid in how we define
problems
do you think
that's good
uh
so
it's a first of all uh you know like i
really like this dichotomy that you
mentioned uh
you know i think it really matters
whether uh inputs are generated by
nature or by humans uh nature uh tends
to be nice you know like uh
you know sometimes it's even you know as
nice as gaussian
uh
you know doesn't always happen but uh
uh you know nature generally doesn't uh
you know uh work against you right you
know humans are much more messy
and uh
you know at the moment when you have
humans you know we have interactions you
have feedback loops you know components
uh and you know occasionally uh
adversaries right so that's that's where
the
uh
you know situation becomes much worse
right so um yeah so the worst case
analysis you know was designed to handle
everything uh right no matter what the
input is
uh the methods that uh you know many of
you guys mentioned you know whether it's
uh you know
why sad suddenly becomes easy or uh you
know like other problems become easy
right
uh
you know they
uh this is this is a phenomenon and you
know it has something to do with the
complexity of the instances
uh
yeah personally
uh
you know like we theoreticians really
like to have uh clean models right so uh
you know i think that this is something
that we we aim to but uh you know
personally i think that uh you know
ultimately uh
you know we might not be able to explain
you know why certain uh uh
you know certain problems some certain
inputs are uh easy or hard uh but the
fact that we cannot quite explain that
it doesn't mean that we cannot exploit
it right so that's uh uh you know like
that's that's that's where this uh uh i
you know idea of uh trying to
characterize the input uh uh implicit
input complexity implicitly comes in
right so uh you know the input might not
be gaussian it might not be
uh
you know like a
you know beyond worst-case analysis you
know according to some
uh clean definitions right but uh the
fact that uh you know the we might not
have a simple characterization of that
it doesn't mean that we cannot use it
and uh so maybe this is a kind of a
pessimistic perspective on things but i
i think that this is uh you know
something to uh
you know potentially look at
do you
yeah yes please
one thing i i guess is whether humans
generated it or science generated and so
on
is not
i think we shouldn't probably worry
about it in other words it's not our
department right so i would like our
models of data to be simple and nice
for instance independence between data
points
it's not always valid but
gaussian or uniform or power loss some
simple things so worst case should be
replaced by something just as clean
but
quote unquote more realistic is is what
i think would happen this is
controversial but um i don't think we
are going to spend time understanding
how data all data is generated
okay well
so um
let me
so suggest like a different viewpoint
maybe
we should kind of sometimes reverse the
quantifiers
so usually we look at an algorithmic
problem
and then look at
the algorithms that solve that problem
but um often what what happens
is that there are actually algorithms
that people are using and maybe it would
be good to take an existing algorithm or
algorithmic approach and find the
problems
that
or instances that it solves
so be careful about quantified reversals
right instead of there exists an
algorithm for all inputs you don't want
to say for all inputs that exist now no
no okay what i mean is
treat the algorithm as the object of
study
[Music]
um
yeah absolutely i mean certainly this is
very important right whether it's
gradient descent like i've mentioned or
you know learning whale communication
where you have some
you actually have uh methods to do these
maximizing probabilities or i was
thinking actually the two stocks talks
that stuck in my mind of course the
chips and salad talk and the mermaid
stock and then
the chips and salad makes me think of
you know something like the small worlds
model right
where you're coming up with a model that
explains a phenomenon
in this case we want to
have a model of data which explains an
algorithm's success
i think that's a great uh beyond worst
case uh perspective
some structure plus randomness often
works but maybe that's not it you need
some insight into what the actual model
is okay
um
so one other thing that that your talk
mentioned ravi is that um
sometimes
you know so in worst case analysis we
try to measure the time in terms of the
input size
but
the input size may actually be a
function of the algorithmic approach
in many cases
so
or the problem formulation
so um and you mentioned like sample
complexity
uh
so you know the more samples you have
the bigger the input size is and the
slower the algorithms are allowed to be
but maybe an n squared algorithm that
actually uses
a much smaller value of n
is preferable to a linear time algorithm
that needs a lot more samples
[Music]
and pack learning model was a departure
from uh this right it said you if you
have enough data your answer is going to
be correct however you find it and then
there's another question of how much
data do you need to actually run the
algorithm yeah so it separated these two
points
yeah so
um do you think there are other
situations
where we could
like look at algorithms
from the point of view of
how much data do we need to collect to
run the algorithm yeah indeed for
unsupervised learning for clustering
actually the simplest sense of mixture
learning
how much data is there for you to be
able to assert the algorithm i run i
have found the correct mixture of the
correct clustering
that's an open question i think yeah
um avraham do you have
sophia
oh sure okay great
[Music]
uh chaffee could you use a mic
so the question to pewter on your slide
you had this one point where you were
saying that some problems share
um
could you give an example to elaborate
can you elaborate on that point
uh well so i i wasn't really saying
anything deep right so you know i'm i'm
thinking about uh situations you know
like you were in a company you know
every every night you have to process
the data that i came the day before
right so you know smartly the data from
day to day are not that different
uh
but they are of course not the same
right so there is some patterns there
are some patterns in this data you
uh
might not be able to necessarily
explicitly characterize it right so uh i
agree completely with uh ravi that if we
can cleanly characterize things we
should do it by all means right
uh but uh you know i i think that
in many cases it's just difficult right
or or we just don't know how to do it
right
uh so
uh
you know so the question is uh you know
can we exploit this uh uh
you know there are apparent patterns in
the in the input uh
which might not be necessarily
characterized above explicitly but uh
you know implicitly right and you know
can we lend such a structure and uh can
we
use the structure to improve algorithms
so i thought you were talking about the
fact that maybe if you have a collection
of instances or collection problems
that's correct but it might be easier to
solve them
as a collection rather than individually
yes because they might give
you know some advice about each other or
there might be a similar structure that
you could discover by having multiple uh
related instances rather than
individually precisely precisely
yeah so uh
yeah so whether it's by finding a
pattern i guess it's finding some kind
of pattern that enables you to find
structure to solve it
yeah yeah so that's that that's that's
what i was referring to so uh you know
like that there are various approaches
uh uh to to this problem i mean one
approach is completely agnostic or
empirical you know just uh train this
thing you know and uh try to find
patterns and then use it uh there has
been some uh theoretical approaches to
that i think you you had a paper uh and
uh
you know it's it's uh you know it's
definitely something that is uh still an
open problem
uh
but i think it's uh uh
you know it's a i i think it's a very
promising approach to you know get the
algorithms faster
i guess my other question was maybe to
cast this
was not on the panel i think you have
some work on evolutionary trees right
about like doing a
longest comment subsequence when you're
assuming that it was gener sequences
were generated by some sort of process
it seems related yeah so right so uh
yeah that's an interesting uh point on
beyond worst case so
sometimes uh
yeah like um
problems aren't be hard if you assume
that the data is just arbitrary
but uh
like in you know like when you try to
learn a model so you you typically you
when you try to learn a model you
shouldn't separate
the source of the data the sourcing of
the data from the problem of
trying to do say maximum likelihood so
like oftentimes when you separate like
if you don't think about where the data
came from
and you think about the problem as an
algorithmic problem hey here's some data
maximize likelihood you may find the
problem is np hard
but if you actually say look you know i
know
my data came from a model of this type
now for that kind of data that was
sampled from a model that comes from a
family i want to do mle
then uh some you know melee oftentimes
is actually not intractable
right so i think that goes back to
uh what the panel was discussing earlier
where we have to like yeah think about
the sourcing of the data is important
and that comes up a lot uh in
this kind of uh
trying to learn a model
okay i mean if you're trying to learn
our model it's reasonable to think that
the data that you use to learn the model
came from a model from some family
and oftentimes not actually sidesteps
interactability results
yeah and there are several examples for
that
thank you
so
no i was just saying you were saying
about coming from nature that we also
have some models of nature that come
from let's say physicists or biologists
we don't have to invent it you know and
we can maybe use those models i think
it's more like what i was saying
you know there are models that people in
the discipline have thought about
you know that have structured their
physical principles to guide them and
though and those could be describing the
inputs that for which we need to design
algorithms and i don't think we do that
much but
maybe we should yeah
um
yeah another challenge i think a return
to your discussion about the algorithm
as a subject right namely i think
a data-driven
algorithmic design once he put the
spotlight he said how do we represent
our algorithm the space of an algorithm
to solve a problem right because
intuitively you want to say there's a
nice space of your algorithm to solve
this problem right and
i think some of the success
largely rely on the somehow you can
have a low dimensional primitive
addition of your
family of algorithm to solve the same
problem and therefore when you see
samples then you begin to be able to
fine-tune uh this underlying
relatively low dimensional
space of algorithm but for in general
uh
i think it's it's a great subject that
is you know we we come here we see so
many beautiful algorithms did i you know
the this advanced data structure for
mike's flow you know the the the
variety of way to do the
convex set right so so those algorithm
if you're asking me how do you
you self-primitize
to somehow able to find find this
algorithm i don't have a clean language
to say what would be the space of an
algorithm that solved the max law right
so what it more generally become much
more complex
so
i yeah
it's a i don't know what but maybe
eventually we are able to get gain much
more insight in
have a language fall
great um so this is uh i hate to to
break up this discussion but i think
we're like way over time today um but
you had one last uh is a giant on our
ario here
so he had a question that he mailed me
so i was wondering if he'd like to ask
oh yes well after the
presentations maybe uh i'm not sure how
relevant it is because uh in the machine
learning community and the information
theory community
the generative models or also known as
planted models that people have been
using those have been
used a lot but
maybe another angle that
that has been also seen is
not not looking at the algorithms for
like the exact maximization or
minimization or approximate of
maximization or minimization of the
function
but to recover the uh like the hidden
true parameter that that created that
right and we have seen that in some of
the problems like matrix uh completion
or or
um like linear uh the sparse linear
regression
and so many other uh cases as well like
uh community detection similar to
clustering etc so uh what i wanted to to
know is that what's the opinion or any
consensus or your opinion about this
monitor because it's not just about or
is not much about the
approximate optimization of a function
but the re guessing the true solution
that generated the model what's the view
of the theoretical cs community has been
used a lot in information theory signal
processing and so but but what's the
view of the theoretical cs community
about that so i think this raises a
bunch of questions so let me try to
repeat them before like giving the
panelists time to respond so one is uh
should we be looking at algorithms
rather than solving problems but to
understand data understand the
distribution the data is coming from i i
think we'd all agree that we should but
maybe people want to comment on what
approaches the other thing is uh planted
models in particular and i think those
are
as santosh mentioned them in this talk
are really good benchmarks for algorithm
design i guess also avram mentioned
semi-random models
uh
as like really good benchmarks where you
have like some structure that you have
that you
has been placed in it and then you're
trying to see whether you can
algorithmically recover or to what
extent you can algorithm recover
this structure
so uh santos maybe you wanna i think
uh
i i guess i mean i would say i i mean i
find these sort of problems of of yeah
so the problems of trying to recover
like a
uh you know a true hidden solution i
think are right they come up a lot and i
think it's a very interesting question
of how you know theoretically to to
model those problems which you could do
through a probability distribution or
you could do through trying to
um understand you know postulate
properties that you you think are
satisfied and then can you come up you
know what properties are sufficient to
recover the answer or
or a small structure that contains the
answer actually i'm kind of heading
towards some work that santosh and anita
did on this in the context of clustering
where you know you could have a purely
uh uh deterministic model but where you
say here are some properties that i th
of the answer i'm looking for with
respect to the data i have can i find an
algorithm that will you know what
properties are sufficient to uniquely
either identify an answer or to get
close
and then sometimes these can lead to
interesting beyond worst case type of
model so for example if you
take clustering and formulate as an
optimization problem
then you're kind of implicitly saying
that the optimal solution to your
optimization ought to be you know the
right answer or something close to it
and if you formulate it as an
optimization problem that's npr and
you're only going to approximately solve
you're sort of implicitly saying that
approximately optimal solutions ought to
be close to the right answer okay so
what does that mean right so i think
that gives you actually you know and and
uh
you know
that gives you a potential okay
formulation that then you can try to
work with so so i think these problems
are very interesting and and how to you
know there's different ways to try to
formulate them that i think can probably
can potentially provide interesting
insights into these
all right anybody have any last comments
are we going to let people ask questions
okay yeah we have one question there
[Music]
yeah thanks for
inspiring discussions so i have a
question about provable analysis
so in some sense provable analysis
actually it's like a worst case
methodology we use in theoretical cs but
in other like theoretical subfield in
like say theoretical physics or
theoretical biology they're not
necessarily like
shooting for like a like a perfect
mathematical guarantees so i'm curious
about like people's thought here i mean
i personally also love mathematical
proofs but is there any possible like
methodology stereotype methodology we
can like vision in the future when we
want to attack those kind of
difficult problems
yeah
so uh so let me
paraphrase again so this question is
like do we to what extent is
theory
uh
does theory mean that we have to have
provable guarantees for algorithms does
the theory of algorithms mean we
provable guarantees to what extent can a
rigorous theory still have
algorithms without provable guarantees
and
so
one thing that comes to mind
is
uh
is
uh i think it's held carp
uh
very early on where they used a uh
lp approximation
to evaluate algorithms
so
often this so that it was an upper bound
on the quality of the solution
and
the algorithms uh
often came within one percent of this
upper bound
so then that's kind of a instance by
instance proof that they're very close
to optimal
you think of other situations where we
have empirical evidence is a big tool in
operations research and machine learning
in other areas
there's a debate whether theory should
allow or do some empirical validation as
well
seems a good idea in a sense but you
have to be very careful because
yeah okay
[Music]
all right yeah that that's how i
interpreted it also yeah i think i think
the question at least correct me find
them was more about the level of
formalism the level of formalism we
usually work in it's essentially just
one step removed from being able to
logically list an entire theorem right
like a step by step but but physicists
for example often use
uh limiting statements that they sort of
believe or are sort of true in principle
but but it's very difficult to write
down a formal proof
right like or the if i i'm like cavity
replica method uh sometimes wrong yeah
yeah so i mean i i don't think we want
to give up the rigor it's okay to change
the problem and relax but yeah i see the
zero minute sign was waving a few
minutes ago so what i'm going to suggest
is that this is a great discussion and
let's uh thank the panelists
and
give people who
actually want to get on with their day
a nice opportunity to leave and then
these chairs are comfortable so we can
continue
[Laughter]
[Applause]